[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este especial sobre
nicaragua en france 24 les saluda jorge
hurtado
2021 quedó registrado como el año donde
la democracia sufre un traspiés en
nicaragua la crisis política y social
que inició en 2018 impulsó a varios
grupos de oposición a aliarse con
diversos partidos políticos para
intentar competir contra daniel ortega
en las elecciones de 2021 después de
superar desacuerdo los opositores se
postularon con la expectativa de sacar a
ortega del poder aún sabiendo que no
habría libre competencia y que no se
contaría como observación internacional
pero en junio el presidente sandinista
inició una feroz cacería contra sus
adversarios electorales encarceló 1 a 1
a los 7 aspirantes presidenciales
también lo hizo con líderes políticos
antiguos guerrilleros y hasta
empresarios el año concluyó con más de
40 personas arrestadas el oficialismo
los acusó de cometer delitos como
traición a la patria o lavado de dinero
sin ninguna figura fuerte como
competencia ortega ganó su tercera
reelección presidencial y sumó un cuarto
mandato consecutivo con su esposa
rosario murillo como vicepresidente del
país tras las críticas al controversial
triunfo por parte de distintas naciones
y organismos el mandatario anunció el
retiro de nicaragua de la organización
de estados américanos oea y rompió
relaciones con taiwán para alinearse con
china comunista la persecución de sus
opositores ha afectado a varias familias
en nicaragua veamos el siguiente reporte
el hogar de margin pozo está marcado por
el presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
su esposo un cronista deportivo cometió
el atrevimiento de criticar al gobierno
en las redes sociales y ahora expresó
político y pues lamentablemente el
pasado 21 de junio fue detenido de
manera arbitraria por pensar diferente
unas semanas anteriores han dado una
campaña de odio simpatizantes de
gobierno contra él donde pedían el
cárcel para miguel
la ausencia de miguel mendoza en su
hogar es emocionalmente devastadora
sobre todo para su hija de siete años y
tras la reelección de ortega las
esperanzas de un reencuentro familiar
disminuyen a la niña le ha perjudicado
un montón o sea a mí que te digo
todas las noches lloramos con la niña y
quizás me puedan ver en el día con una
sonrisa pero también tengo que ser
fuerte tengo que ser fuerte por los tres
monseñor silvio fonseca también ha sido
un crítico del gobierno y aunque es
libre dentro de nicaragua no puede
abandonar el país porque las autoridades
migratorias le decomisaron sus
documentos cuando intentaba viajar para
unos chequeos médicos y hay una
preocupación en la iglesia porque el
pueblo de dios- se siente amenazado en
cuanto no es que tocaron solamente a un
señor asiduo con seca tocaron a la
iglesia
y por esa razón así como lo pueden dejar
salir también no lo pueden dejar entrar
además de algunas familias nicaragüenses
y la iglesia también los jóvenes han
estado bajo la represión gubernamental
santiago fajardo participó de las
masivas protestas de 2018 y ahora
intenta reconstruir su vida tras pasar
meses en prisión decidí exiliarme cuando
me vais al ejército y me echaron por eso
tuve casi un año preso vaart y todo como
dicen de carahue se sale con una mano
adelante y la otra atrás cuando salí a
la cárcel santiago he tenido que
esforzarse para conseguir nuevas
oportunidades su marca de ser opositor
pone tranca a sus emprendimientos se me
crearon esa fuente de negocio en mi
cabeza y logré yo hoy estoy aquí no fue
fácil
no daban para secuestrar a los
repartidores para ver se le quitaba la
moto antes a los repartidores en medio
de la discusión política sobre la
legitimidad de las últimas elecciones
realizadas en noviembre estos
nicaragüenses despiden un año turbulento
en sus vidas y aún les queda la
incertidumbre de lo que ocurrirá en el
país en los próximos cinco años con
ortega y murillo en el poder en este
nuevo escenario político los expertos
señalan que la oposición por ahora
desorientada con el arresto de sus
líderes deberá reorganizarse bajo nuevos
mecanismos desde el exterior en materia
económica se prevé una reducción de la
inversión pública y de la llegada de
nuevas inversiones al país aunque las
remesas y las exportaciones se verán
beneficiadas por el efecto rebote post
pandemia en este contexto daniel ortega
dos señales de querer ir a diálogo
nacional en el 2022 sin embargo el
panorama sigue siendo desalentador para
los nicaragüenses el gobierno sandinista
se enrumba a un mayor aislamiento
internacional tomando como refugio a
china continental y ajustando sus
políticas económicas para asegurar la
permanencia en el poder bajo un control
total de las instituciones y las fuerzas
armadas
hasta aquí con este especial sobre
nicaragua en france 24
[Música]